newly released body camera video gives
us a closer look at the so-called House
of Horrors in Arizona where 55 dogs were
seized in September their owner now
facing allegations of housing the dogs
in a biohazard and abusing her elderly
mother adult detector what does that
mean so so it's like child care services
only for an old lady on September 22nd
dozens of dogs were seized from April
McLaughlin's home in Chandler Arizona
but months before police were called to
the scene for a different reason she's
saying that she's being mistreated by
her daughter in June chandeler police
received a call about McLaughlin's
mother Kathleen McLaughlin who reported
elder abuse at the hand of her daughter
Kathleen had been at the library and
reported she was being mistreated it was
reported by someone else where she went
to a library and they reported it to us
I I'm I'm speaking with her now getting
some more clarity about
it she's saying
that her daughter she she doesn't have
power attorney so C makes her own
decision suffered a
stroke um a while
ago maybe the first of this year I I
don't know for certain but she said she
suffered a stroke the caller reported
Kathleen didn't have access to her
wallet with her banking information and
ID the caller also said Kathleen didn't
have a phone she's saying that she don't
have access to a bank account anymore
because her daughter has changed the
password I'm going to go check with the
bank to see if I can get some
verification for
that um she's saying that her daughter
had taken away her
phone which uh prevents her from from
being able to call out to anyone
M um she had mentioned
that the daughter taking a a wallet and
a ID and all that other stuff but she
just told me that she found a wallet
with her ID but she don't
have her um she don't have a phone she
don't have a bank card the caller also
made note of dozens of dogs within
McLaughlin's home she's saying that
she's being mistreated by her daughter I
don't know if it's true okay um I don't
know if she has SMI I I'll know a little
more once I talk to her daughter and
maybe once you get to speak to her um I
do know that she she told me that
there's about 202 dogs in
home I call I've called Animal Control
already on June 30th a Chandler police
officer responded to April McLaughlin's
home video shows the officer approached
the
scene got a couple questions for you
okay what do you want me to do you want
me to stay in hard or what do you want
me to do you can step out if you want
you're in trouble just you live here
right I do okay so um adult protect
Services the officer explains he's there
for a welfare check on McLaughlin's
mother
Kathleen adult detective what does that
mean so so it's like child care services
only for an old lady yeah it's for it's
uh basically like uh they look out for
older people that can't take care of
themselves yeah type of thing well she
can take care of herself she just that's
what I'm here to find out oh yeah so
somebody called in something that said
that they wanted a well check on it so
that's what we're here
for so it's bizarre okay I've never had
that happen April tells the officer her
mother has dementia before mentioning
her dogs for the first time a few things
uhhuh I have to I have a dog in the back
that I had C through the Ved so I have
to take him in that's fine um do you
want to see her is that what you want to
see her talk to her real quick okay
that's it okay is she of right mind and
everything like she take care she does
have dementia yeah so how long's that
been going on probably like a year and a
half so um yeah no she has dementia
that's why she's here we can't afford to
put her in a home you know what I mean
she can dress herself eat herself all
that stuff okay yeah so so can I can I
put my dog away though okay so he's a
special needs dog I have special needs
dog
so all right well they have to get the
all right so I'm going to back in I have
to take my dog around the side April
explains her dog has special needs and
needs to be carried inside to get my dog
I have to carry him in oh no problem hot
no this isn't hot yet it's not hot yet
okay well yeah I know but still it's
still hot even though it's going to get
hot while waiting for April to return
the officer speaks with a neighbor
nearby the man admits he's heard the
dogs barking
before how you doing good how are you
good do you know the people live here
who who lives here is a woman and her
and her mom yeah how are they she's
quiet I mean aside from the dogs barking
time is that what you're here for but
the neighbor says he's never actually
seen April's mother kathle how long's
this lady been with her mom here I don't
know that I can't tell you like this car
and all that yeah that that's the way
she parks and she I just talked to her
there's just some accusations that she's
not letting her she's taking over all
her money and everything else but I
don't know if it's a dementia thing I
don't know if it's a dementia thing call
no yeah APS did APS so somebody called
APS got with a tip like this so seen man
I'll be honest with you she told me
she's in there I've never seen okay so
she's going to have me talk for her so
if you need anything I'm here all right
thanks man appreciate
it after speaking with the neighbor the
officer heads back toward April's home
from the outside multiple dogs can be
heard barking and
whining seconds later when April
reappears she's accompanied by her
mother
Kathleen's a bunch of you want to stay
in the shade so you're not blaring in
the heat here yeah is there a shady
spot no shade there shade right there is
there a shade right
here the front door over here yeah
here's fine is that better for you yeah
I can hear you better cuz the dogs are
kind of barking oh
yeah these have a lot of oh those are
the thorny ones huh yeah so um my name
is Officer Thomas sheski with Chandler
Police Department Kathleen explains she
does have concerns living with her
daughter mentioning multiple dogs I'm
just here to make sure that that
uh everything's fine with you you don't
do you have anything that you're
concerned about living
here well no um no we I we are looking
at different a different place way to
live okay all
right
say she's got so many dos
okay Kathleen denies calling anyone for
help saying she doesn't have a phone
that's when April steps in saying her
mother does have access to a phone how
long have you guys been living together
here about a year and a half 2 years a
year and a half year and a half year and
a okay so
um um did you did you make any phone
calls to anybody do you remember no
because I don't have a phone for some
reason she didn't she know just want me
out phone oh does she have a phone or no
she does okay when I see it I'll believe
it when the officer doubles down asking
about abuse allegations both women say
there are no issues is there anything
that that you wanted to talk to the
police about
as far as um any kind of uh alleged
abuse or anything like that or living
conditions or
anything no recently
uh since I met met you it's it's been
better since
when
uh 6 months ago okay right so next the
officer asks whether April has power of
attorney over her mother is there a
power of attorney involved in this are
you a legal power of attorney and all
that to make I'd like to see that is
there we did it because I took it to all
our appointments and everything else
when so is it medical an aate everything
100% I have full say on everything that
happen do you have any of that paperwork
with you not that I can provide right
now no okay cuz I have to report back to
this APS guy and and if I don't have
anything that says what you're saying
then he has to keep digging cuz that's
what they do when the officer asks for
proof April says she doesn't have easy
access to the paperwork I'm trying to
put this baby to bed right now no I do
the unfortunately like I'm in the middle
of moving so I'm packing and moving
everything and that is not something
that's if I I can't go in there and be
like okay let me go in this box and find
it literally that's where I how long do
you think it would take you to find it a
few get back to me a few days if you
give me your car I can you want me an
email to you or I can I'll give you an
email and then you can email that
information that way I have all the
paper otherwise he's the guy who's
calling is going to he's either going to
come over here A bunch of times or he's
going to want to see that kind of stuff
you know what I'm saying April explains
she became Power of Attorney after she
says her mother was scammed so when did
that go down the whole p uh a year and a
half ago when she first went in so a
year and a half ago is when you you
filed and got all the paperwork for 100%
there's a um yeah um my my book both my
aunts her sisters agreed because she was
she got taken for five grand from a
scammer from email from a phone call I
mean that's where we're at now this is
this your comes in and out so complete
Finance everything so I have the banks
everything okay um because of because it
was just and she she she forgets where
her phone is she forgets where she puts
everything right and then she that's
where the L is happening um okay um and
the she has a neurologist a doctor I've
taken her all of appointments and I
don't want her have want her on the
computer to get scammed they don't want
her making phone calls to people and
getting scammed opening does she ever go
anywhere do you ever take her anywhere
yeah went to library oh Library when was
that yesterday but once every R every uh
what three months month or two yeah so
when I asked her to go to the grocery
store she says she's too tired I'll go
tomorrow can we go tomorrow it's like
kind of like the same thing so if I
asked her to go every day maybe I would
say once every 10 days she might want to
go okay Library she she enjoy always
going to the library she was there for
several hours like 5 hours yesterday
April tells the officer her mother's
health is on the decline every day every
month it's gotten kind of worse um okay
deterioration so we're just trying to
find her a better place the officer then
gives April his contact information in
hopes of receiving the paperwork it's
Kevin dameski at Chandler e.gov okay oh
good yeah yeah just uh I could probably
find it in two days yeah if you can find
it send it over that way that
way that prevents them sending people
over here prevents a lot of stuff so um
oh because yeah they know that I'm
making all the decisions exactly yeah
okay so that way if somebody accuses
somebody of something I know they know
who's in charge and who who's who's
allowed to make decisions and you know
what I'm saying so yeah I can send it I
don't mind what do you so you just need
the major power of attorney thing just
yeah just whatever it's the paperwork
that shows that you are in control of of
is is it finance and health yeah okay
like all the like no one can do Health
on her without my authorization
basically no one I mean we talk about it
and there's two separate ones right
one's for finance or estate whatever on
for both I got them all on purpose cuz
she can when we go to the bank for
instance like I have access to
everything but she's has you know she
has some say but I have access to it
that's where we're at okay before the
recording concludes Kathleen assures the
officer she's okay all right do you have
any questions for me ma'am no right now
okay well I'm glad you she said yeah I'm
glad you uh you're feeling better and
you're you're talking good yeah and uh
next month better and
better that's good all right you have
any questions for me or anything this is
just a while check can I get the records
am I allowed to just like I'm allowed to
look up the records on who called I can
I can get yeah what let me give you the
report I'll put it on there yeah so
basically it sounds
like something stem from the
library whether did she talk to somebody
at the library maybe possibly that's
what I'm guessing and then the library
called APS and APS called us thank you
bottom line that's all I need know
pretty much yeah I don't know exactly
what was said but it was enough to do a
well check yeah
that's
I'll give you the report number though
I'll be right back months later on
September 22nd Chandler police served a
search warrant at April's home after
receiving reports from a local vet the
report noted uncertain conditions for
three dogs but when officials arrived
they found 55 dogs after that the dogs
were placed with the Arizona Humane
Society for medical care Kathleen was
also home at the time the dogs were
taken April McLaughlin initially faced
charges of animal cruelty and adult
abuse but the Maricopa County Attorney's
Office later dropped those charges and
sent the investigation back to Chandler
PD April has since petitioned the court
for the return of her 13 dogs but a
judge denied this request reporting for
longw Crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie